you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution
let's talk about how bone remodeling the
actual process has changed over time so
you've done research specifically in
when did these different types of bone
cells emerge throughout evolutionary
history and you just published a big
paper on that
yeah do you want to talk about that for
a little bit here sure absolutely
this this kind of comes from
reading you know the early textbooks of
biology and just you know learning okay
a b and c
this is what happens this is how bones
this is how bones do
the end
and then i was like okay cool we we know
how bones do and then i made the mistake
of looking at fish
uh and it was a mistake because fish are
incredibly complicated and they stem
from way before tetrapods right so they
come way down farther in the tree than
than we do and so that doesn't mean
they're more primitive at least modern
fish does not mean they're more
primitive it just means they took a
different branch of life and they had a
different tool set to work with so
everything turns out everything looks
really different in fish and they just
play by their own rules which makes my
life really complicated
yeah so
i saw what fish modern fish were doing i
saw what you know modern mammals us and
reptiles and every i think everything is
alive today we're doing and i wanted to
just trace it back and see when certain
divergence divergences happen
so to understand to understand why
this is cool i have to
give you guys a little bit of bone 101
yeah so
one quick question first what what group
of fish were you looking at chilios bony
bony fish uh basically the ones that
make up
the vast majority so think tuna think
salmons think uh oppa not sharks so like
bony fish the ones that you would that
would end up on your dinner table
nothing extremely special nothing
extremely specialized and they were
still doing everything
really differently then
then all the textbooks said because
apparently nobody looks at fish
so
when you're looking for these rules that
are supposed to guide all bone you know
like
you you they have to apply to all
animals that have bone otherwise they're
not rules and
therefore you have to dig deeper and for
me digging deeper means digging deeper
in time
so
bone 101
so you got to know that basically
there's three bone cell types that you
just have to keep in mind there's the
bone building cells osteoblasts
your bone destroying cells your
osteoclasts
and your osteocytes which i call your
bone maintaining cells are the ones that
kind of keep everyone in line they
orchestrate bone remodeling they
orchestrate
a bunch of different things they sense
pressure in your bone they kind of they
live in the bone and they have think of
squid arms or octopus arms and they
reach out everywhere so there's a bunch
of those and they're the most numerous
so there's your three cell types
now
all books say that they'll show you
three cell types
one and done
that's it
right so it's pretty insane that the
vast majority of living vertebrates
today
the vast majority
don't have osteosites
and olives
which is just like
come on you guys like you cannot follow
a single roll like rude
so i looked back in time and realized
they did have osteocytes um at some
point in the cretaceous and then lost it
and some things lost it even more
recently we're not a 100 sure there's a
couple of new papers that are coming out
about exactly when certain things were
lost anyway
they come from ancestors that had
osteocytes
yeah okay great great we're back to
following the rules but if you go back
just even a little bit farther before
jaws evolved before
limbs evolved before any of that so
you're looking at mud slurping jawless
fish early devonian solarian the
earliest vertebrates armored jawless
fish and you look at them the earliest
ones again don't have osteocytes
and
they don't have visible osteonal
remodeling the type of remodeling that
we talked about earlier that's guided by
uh your blood vessels okay they don't
have it it doesn't exist
okay
so now we know that all our bones and
all the all the superpowers that our
modern bone has hasn't always existed
but they were acquired through evolution
and possibly in a stepwise
fashion possibly all at once with one
animal we're still not 100 sure when you
look a little bit later there's another
jawless fish that has osteocytes and has
a bunch of other features that makes us
think okay those are the ancestors to
jaw invertebrates and then from those
the earliest jawed vertebrates are the
ones that have osteonal remodeling and
from there you get you know all your
splits of cartilaginous fish and ray
fent fish and all the fish that we have
today and then sarcopterisians the lobe
fin fish the ones that lead eventually
to us
tetrapods
the story of bone is basically the story
of vertebrates it starts right at the
beginning
uh with
a really extremely
simplified external armor they look like
beetles they have only bone on the
outside they don't have any bone on the
inside oh i did not know that okay they
have no bone on the inside it's a
cartilaginous skeleton on the inside
bone on the outside only and the bone on
the outside is covered in
pause for effect
dentine
which is what our teeth are made of yeah
which is crazy
so the first tissues that make our teeth
today actually started out as ways that
our
mud slurping ancestors protected
themselves
yeah so that's the story of bone that's
the story of teeth they're all
interconnected and
i got asked a really good question which
is why
you know
why
did they need all this armor why do they
need to put teeth on the outside and
bone why did bone evolve in the first
place right you get to that point where
okay so not everything existed not all
the features existed why did the very
first
mud slurping fish even evolve what was
the point you know maybe they were happy
to be soft squirmy wormy things why did
why didn't we just continue down that
road
and the the answer is very likely
because of euripids these giant sea
scorpions
that try to basically eat our early
vertebrate ancestors and they're like
this is not this is not how we're doing
this i would rather be armored and
survive thank you
and that's how vertebrate mineralization
likely started from that predation
pressure
so we can thank scorpions and arachnids
for our skeletons basically that's what
i'm trying to say nice
nice
okay editor john here what yara i just
said there is so important that i just i
have to restate it not because you
didn't state it well enough but because
it's so important i want people to to
really understand this
it appears that our skeletons and our
teeth the molecular precursors the genes
that we now use to build our skeletons
in our teeth those evolved during an
arms race
with ancient marine arthropods or again
as yara put it
so
we can thank scorpions and arachnids for
our skeletons basically that's what i'm
trying to say
well that's it for this clip but don't
worry i post clips regularly and every
thursday i post completely fresh content
make sure you're subscribed
liking and commenting is also welcome